we haven't heard much from President
Trump on the subject since North Korea
started going squishy on the idea of his
summit but today the president was in a
chatty mood and still optimistic that
North Korea will come to the table
in the Oval Office with NATO
secretary-general today President Trump
revealed that despite intemperate
language from North Korea in recent days
his June summit with Kim jong-un appears
to still be on track nothing has changed
on North Korea that we know of we have
not been told anything and if it does
that's fine if it doesn't I think we'll
probably have a very successful meeting
in statements made earlier this week
North Korea singled out comments from
National Security Advisor John Bolton
described to Chris Wallace what he said
was the White House's vision for North
Korean disarmament we have very much in
mind the Libya model from 2003 2004
there are obviously differences the
living program was much smaller but that
was basically the agreement that we made
North Korea was only too quick to remind
the world that eight years after Muammar
Gadhafi shipped his nuclear program to
Tennessee the u.s. turned on him the US
and NATO Jets helping to overthrow
Gaddafi who was later murdered in the
streets by an angry mob with the
National Security Adviser looking on
president Trump today said the model for
North Korean disarmament will be much
different than Libya the Libyan model
isn't a model that we have at all while
we're thinking of North Korea in Libya
we decimated that country we never said
to Qadhafi oh we're going to give you
protection we're going to give you
military strength we're going to give
you all of these things the president
indicated that in return for dismantling
his nuclear program Kim will get
guarantees economic security and
political he'd be in his country he'd be
running his country his country would be
very rich what security guarantees are
you willing we're willing to do a lot
and he's willing to I think do a lot
also and I think we'll actually have a
good relationship assuming we have the
meeting and assuming something comes of
it and he'll get protections that will
be very strong but president Trump also
warned
Libyan model could loom in Kim Jong Un's
future now that model would take place
if we don't make a deal most likely but
if we make a deal I think Kim jong-un is
going to be very very happy the
president has talked about wanting to
reduce the size of the US protection
force in South Korea down from the
current 28,500 troops North Korea has
long demanded that the u.s. removed
troops from South Korea today president
Trump wouldn't say if that is on the
table I'm not going to talk about that
we're going to say that he will have
very adequate protection and we'll see
how it all turns out I think this the
best thing he could ever do is to make a
deal in these meetings with the NATO
secretary-general today president Trump
also highlighted the differences between
how he is prepared to treat North Korea
and how he may treat Iran going forward
saying that any new sanctions against
Iran will be quote brutal Brett John
Roberts lauded the North law and John
thanks